il ya tout juste dix ans l'inauguration
du gazoduc nord stream ii et l'union
européenne qui tarde toujours à
certifier le second gazoduc inouïe sa
construction est pourtant terminée
depuis septembre est en pleine crise de
l'énergie en europe la russie appelle
l'allemagne à approuver son lancement
les précisions de notre correspondante à
moscou vera goffman
dix ans après le lancement de son grand
frère dans stream la polémique ne cesse
pas autour de nord stream de ce nouveau
gazoduc qui roulait l'allemagne à la
russie sur fond d'envolée des prix de
gaz qui frappe durement le consommateur
européen
le e dont environ un tiers des besoins
en gaz sont couvertes par moscou tarde à
donner la certification pour le pipe
line pour vladimir poutine l'europe est
la seule responsable de la crise des
prix du gaz notamment en n'ayant pas
conclu suffisamment de contrats de
livraisons sur le long terme avec la
russie je vous propose d'écouter déficit
le déficit en gaz sur le marché européen
pourrait atteindre le chiffre de 70
milliards de mètres cubes c'est beaucoup
mais pourquoi que sont la russie c'est
le résultat de la politique menée par la
commission européenne
la russie n'a rien à voir avec cela
la russie est notamment gazprom a acquis
l'offre en gaz sur le marché européen de
manière générale il ya se promena
augmenté de 8,7 pour cent si je m'abuse
côté allemand on entend des appels à
mettre en service nord stream ii afin de
ne pas exacerber la crise énergétique
écoutez nous renonçons progressivement
au charbon nous renonçons
progressivement nucléaire la raréfaction
des ressources augmente les prix
augmentent la demande en électricité
augmente en raison de la numérisation et
de l'électromobilité
c'est pourquoi nous avons besoin de
centrales électriques au gaz la russie
est cependant prête à entamer les
livraisons vie un hors stream 2 dès que
le gazoduc aura reçu l'autorisation du
régulateur européen